[Music]
hi I'm Eve Hewson and I am here to give
you advice on how to text a girl how
quickly should a guy text a girl after
getting her number it depends when you
got it if you got it that night the next
day is good like 6 yeah don't be too
eager don't wake up to a text don't want
that but don't wait a whole day
[Music]
you
don't open up a conversation and then
not contribute to it I've had people be
like hey what's up how are you great how
are you good okay if you texted me what
do you want you know you kind of have to
be direct Hey
don't send the hey text yeah I know
you're guilty of stunning the hey Tex
your face is like whole guys with the
hey don't send
three days without a response she could
just be playing it really cool I've done
that before two hours chill 12 hours is
cool 24 hours is cool a week is just
like let it go it's not going to happen
a week means that you've just forgotten
about it and it's not important you
can't just send like a sexual picture
and you've only hung out with them once
that's just too much you can't be like
hey check this out
babe and we would like to see this and
be careful of the times that you send
those pictures you know make sure it's
probably like
she could be sitting next to her father
and in church or something